aftermath of the worst terrorist attack
in Europe for a decade the thoughts and
prayers of this hall and our whole
country are with the friends and
families of those affected including the
British victims these were innocent
people going about their lives enjoying
a Friday night out brutally gunned down
by callous murderers murderers who
thought their acts of depravity could
somehow destroy everything we stand for
they could not have been more wrong
Britain France and our allies around the
world will never be cowed by terrorism
we will only redouble our resolve to
defeat it and tonight I want to talk
about how but before I turn to the
specific terrorist threat let me first
say a word about our wider approach to
Britain's national security because at
the heart of the national security
strategy that we publish next week are
some key choices which provide the
foundations from which we can defeat
this terrorist scourge the first choice
is about ensuring our economic security
as I argued at this dinner last year
economic security and our national
security
go hand in hand you cannot have one
without the other
it is only because we have a strong
economy that we can afford the resources
to invest in our national security it's
only because we've halved the deficit
and made our economy the fastest growing
in the g7 last year that we can maintain
the second best funded armed forces in
all of NATO and together with France the
most capable and globally deployed in
Europe so we will continue to see
through our long-term economic plan and
take the difficult decisions to deal
with our deficit second we are using our
economic strengths to invest in hard
military power as I'll explain later
whatever others might wish with a case
the reality is that there are times when
you do need to be able to deploy Millett
force and if you don't have it you can't
deploy it so in a difficult spending
review where resources are tight we are
choosing to spend 2% of our GDP on
defense every year for the rest of the
decade with the growing economy this
means a rising defense budget with more
money every year but it's not just about
the amount of money we spend all the
size of our forces it's also about our
ability to deploy them quickly with the
right equipment to get things done we've
seen how vital drones are in the fight
against ISIL
so with this extra money we are doubling
our fleet of drones we know we need the
ability to carry out airstrikes so this
money will provide for more fighter
aircraft we want to increase the
capabilities of our brilliant Special
Forces so there will be a 2 billion
pound program of new investments over
this Parliament we will maintain our
continuous at sea nuclear deterrent and
will also invest in a new generation of
cyber defenses to block and disrupt
attacks before they can harm our United
Kingdom all these measures and more come
from the choice that we make to spend on
our security to deal head-on with a wide
range of threats that we face today but
keeping our people safe in the modern
world means tackling the causes of the
threats we face not just dealing with
their consequences so the third key
choice that we make is to keep our
promise to the poorest in the world by
spending naught point 7 percent of our
gross national income on aid I've made
the argument many times before that this
is the right thing to do morally and
I've made the argument that it's in our
national interest but tonight I want to
make a slightly different point our aid
budget makes us the fastest in the world
to react at the Migration summit in
Valletta last week as other countries
were struggling to work out their
contribution to the international effort
to stop this lethal trade in human
beings across the world I was able to
say very quickly what we'd spend where
the money would come from what we'd do
we don't need to spend time deliberating
over of wondering whether we can afford
to help out or not we can focus
immediately on what we can do that will
help the most so when a typhoon hits the
Philippines British sailors were among
the first to arrive with Ebola in Africa
I knew we could afford to act and act
comprehensively and it was the rapid
contribution of British forces
humanitarian workers and medical staff
who helped to make Sierra Leone Ebola
free last week and prevent the spread of
this dreadful disease around the world
this ability to respond swiftly flexibly
generously means that we have a big
impact on the way that the world
responds to crises and we're going to
enhance that capability by refocusing
our aid spending so we'll target at
least half of Defense budget on
stabilizing and supporting broken and
fragile states and do so much more to
help refugees closer to their homes this
will make our aid spending an even more
fundamental part of our strategy to keep
our country safe and it will help to
maintain Britain's position as number
one in the world for soft power and yes
it may be called soft power but whether
it's saving the lives of refugees by
stopping them from having to make that
terrible journey across the
Mediterranean whether it's helping the
Lebanese build defenses against ISIL
whether it's helping countries establish
the building blocks of democracy of
justice of rule of law I can tell you
that soft power packs a real punch now
the fourth key choice we've made is
taking in taking a comprehensive
approach to our security is to engage
with countries around the world even
when there are difficult issues to
address now some people said I shouldn't
have invited the leaders of India China
and Egypt to Britain in recent weeks
others concluded that it's a sort of
zero-sum game with the drawbacks of
engagement being balanced out exactly by
the benefits to our trade frankly I
disagree with both of those views it's
not just about trade important as that
is it is about influence it's about
using our world-class diplomatic network
to build relationships that mean you can
work together to solve shared problems
and have the ability to express concerns
where you need to think about the
consequences of not engaging is anyone
really saying that I shouldn't talk to
the Egyptians on the day after an
airliner is blown up in their country
and when it's in Britain's national
interest that we support their airport
security and get our own people safely
home
the people who wanted me to raise the
dumping of cheap steel with the Chinese
are also often the same people who say I
shouldn't meet the Chinese in the first
place
well I can't raise the issue if I'm not
talking to them just as we can't
influence their rise in the world if
we're not willing to engage the bottom
line is this yes it is a strategic
choice to engage with countries where we
have concerns but my view is this you
can't conduct foreign policy by press
releases and pious statements in
Parliament you have to engage and build
the alliances that can make a difference
a deeper partnership means a deeper
conversation and a greater ability to
address the issues that might concern us
so the national security strategy that
we're publishing next week will give
Britain the resources it needs to
increase both it's hard and soft power
and build the relationships that can
project and enhance our influence in the
world and it's against this background
that I want to turn specifically to the
terrorist threat that we face the more
we learn about what happened in Paris
the more it justifies the approach they
were taking in Britain when you're
dealing with radicalized European
Muslims linked to ISIL in Syria and
inspired by a poisonous narrative of
extremism you need an approach that
covers the full spectrum military power
counterterrorism expertise and defeating
the poisonous narrative that is the root
cause of this evil let me take each in
turn we have to be realistic and
hard-headed about the threats we face
confronting this murderous violence
requires a strong security response
those who say we should have somehow
arrested jihadi john' don't get the
reality of the world we are in the same
is true of Junaid Hussain or riad Khan
there is no government we can work with
in Syria let alone that part of Syria
there are no rigorous police
investigations or independent courts
upholding justice in Raqqa
we have no military on the ground to
detain those preparing plots and there
was nothing to suggest that any of these
people would ever leave Syria or stop
planning to murder British and American
citizens in that situation you do not
protect people by sitting around and
wishing for another world you have to
act in this world and that means being
prepared to use military force where
necessary turning to counterterrorism
our security services have fall coiled
no fewer than seven different terrorist
plots right here in Britain over the
past year alone we should all be
extraordinarily grateful for the work
they have done in thwarting these
attacks and keeping us safe
but we need to do more to ensure our
agencies have the resources and the
information they need to prevent and
disrupt plots against this country at
every stage so in next week strategic
defence and security review will make a
major additional investment in our
world-class intelligence agencies
this will include over 1,900 additional
security and intelligence staff and more
money to increase our network of
counterterrorism experts in the Middle
East in North Africa South Asia and
sub-saharan Africa we will also more
than double our spending on aviation
security around the world with more
experts overseas working side-by-side
with host nations in the most vulnerable
locations we also need to do more to
make sure the powers we give our
security services keep pace with changes
in technology so we published a draft
bill that would ensure that GCHQ mi5 and
our counterterrorism police continue to
have the powers to follow terrorist
movements by tracking their online
communications to intercept those
communications under a warrant and to
obtain data from computers used by
terrorists and pedophiles now of course
there will be those who criticize these
measures having them as an infringement
of civil rights I disagree
they are about protecting those
liberties from terrorists who want to
take them away and furthermore these are
powers that have been used in every
major recent counterterrorism
investigation by mi5 and the police and
they've played an important part in
thwarting many attacks from a plot to
blow up the London Stock Exchange in
2010 to a sickening attempt to imitate
the killers of Lee Rigby by murdering a
soldier with a knife and a hammer in
August last year our legislation will
get the balance right with powers
matched by strong safeguards and
judicial oversight to make us world
leaders on transparency and
accountability but military power and
counterterrorism expertise will only get
us so far to defeat this terrorist
threat in the long term we must also
understand
and address its root cause there is far
too much confusion about this some say
it is wronged husbands getting revenge
on the Western wrongdoers but this
overlooks that ISIL al-qaida boko haram
they murder muslims in huge numbers some
say it is because of the iraq war
that overlooks that 9/11 the biggest
loss of british citizens in a terrorist
attack happened before the Iraq war some
say it's because of poverty and
deprivation but that overlooks that many
of these terrorists have had the full
advantages of prosperous families or a
Western education I'm not saying that
these issues aren't important but we
could deal with all of them and some
people would still be drawn to extremism
the root cause of this threat is the
poisonous ideology of extremism itself
this ideology this disease view of the
world has become an epidemic infecting
minds from the mosques of Mogadishu to
the bedrooms of Birmingham and we have
to stop it at the start stop this seed
of hatred even being planted in people's
minds let alone allowing it to grow and
that means confronting the ideology with
our own liberal values exposing this
extremism for what it is a belief system
that glorifies violence and subjugates
its people not least Muslim people it
means tackling both the violent and the
non violent extremism in all its forms
because unwittingly or not those who
promote extremist views even if
nonviolent themselves are providing
succor to those who want to commit or
get others to commit violence it means
improving integration by moving away
from a segregation in our schools and
communities and inspecting and shutting
down any educational institutions that
are teaching intolerance and it means
actively encouraging reforming and
moderate Muslim voices to speak up and
challenge the extremists
and this final point is vital of course
this extremist ideology is not true
Islam that cannot be said clearly enough
but it's not good enough to say simply
that Islam is a religion of peace and
then to deny any connection between the
religion of Islam and the extremists why
well because these extremists are self
identifying as Muslims from Tunisia to
the streets of Paris these murderers all
spout the same twisted narrative that
claims to be based on a particular faith
so to deny that is to disempower the
critical reforming voices that want to
challenge the scriptural basis on which
extremists claim to be acting the voices
that are crucial in providing an
alternative worldview that could stop a
teenager's slide along the spectrum of
extremism we cannot stand neutral in
this battle of ideas we have to back
those who share our values with
practical help with funding with
campaigns
protection and political representation
this is a central part of how we can
defeat this terrorism in the long term
and it's a battle of ideas that we must
win not just here at home but together
with our allies all around the world
this will be a huge challenge but in
Britain we have the soft power the
influence the educational expertise and
the alliances with other countries to
win this battle and defeat the causes of
hatred and intolerance that threaten our
security and the security of our allies
across the world Lord we're here in this
great gilt wall is a copy of the Magna
Carta signed just months before the
first Lord Mayor show 800 years ago and
enshrining in this land the principles
of liberty justice and the rule of law
as this stops this Hall stood open to
the sky after the bombings of London in
the heat of the Second World War it was
Winston Churchill who addressed this
banquet as it temporarily moved
to mansion-house he spoke of the resolve
of this ancient city of London and our
determination that however long and hard
the toil may be the British nation would
never enter into negotiations with
Hitler it is that historic British
resolve that we celebrate here again
tonight and it is that same resolve that
will defeat this terrorism and ensure
that the values that we believe in and
the values we defend will again in the
end prevail thank you
you